la eliminación de Alemania es sin duda
un golpe muy fuerte para una selección
que hace apenas 8 años era campeona del
mundo pero que desde entonces ha estado
en una muy profunda crisis esa crisis es
quizás una de las razones por las cuales
los alemanes no han estado siguiendo tan
de cerca esta copa del mundo en
comparación con torneos anteriores pero
no es la única razón los temas políticos
relacionados con los derechos humanos en
Qatar el boicot de algunos bares y
establecimientos públicos y un mundial
que se realiza en pleno invierno han
contribuido a ese ambiente poco emotivo
de parte de los alemanes y ni siquiera
en televisión los alemanes parecen estar
siguiendo el mundial muy de cerca los
ratings han estado comparativamente
Bajos en comparación con torneos
anteriores Y en ocasiones incluso
películas de suspenso han tenido más
espectadores que partidos del Mundial
Sin embargo a raíz de esta eliminación
es muy probable que en los próximos días
haya un debate muy fuerte en Alemania
sobre el que deberá tomar la selección
tras esta debacle en el mundial de Qatar